I chose to work with ice because
it contradicts the concepts of the
official monument the moment that is big I made it
small and the monument that is made
for eternity I made one to disappear
[Music]
my name is debtor I am a visual artist I
am Brazilian live  in são paulo
[Music]
on the street no one looks at the play it's a lot of
people so a state of suspension
awakens awareness in the community
[Music]
I've already done the other work that is a
moment me in 24 cities around the
world
the state  of suspension it was never
made the invitation of color live made it possible for
me to put this project here in Brazil the
state of suspension is a
performance installation you put aluminum pans and
bowls with a microphone
that will capture the sounds cultures
is to see these sounds of melting  and
this sound is very important because it wakes up
to this disappearance I've never done it
but the farm worried to stop more than
900 culture and not be possible to hang
embassy fried with  Sculptures wo
n't pity
our people and it hurts I spent two years
researching materials until I arrived
on the ice
I started doing 1 to 1 a little bit
that only the work starts asking the street
so I have to do a
lot of genius like him  disappears i stopped
making objects
but music we do like this
theater is like that dance is like that
you work work and present and
that's it
[Music]
the three of you can now take the streets full of
spines hole terrone pg
[Music]
me  I like the art of shapes it's something
you have to see there it's something you
charge and take the stab being suspended
here I don't feel fully
represented
when I have this line suspended with
them
[Music]
the melting sculptures puts you
in front of your subjectivity  and in the
collective feeling
I seek in every moment of my life to
make me think and act together so much that I
think life is the great art
I think life is the great work
[Music]
the